a monkey
start the storm routine
[Music]
okay pay attention to the in between so
it's more important anything okay so
when I see this is keeping him out he
removed his weapon from the centerline I
paid him and he made him have to throw
from out there is going here even we
don't yes so why a one boom it's right
there that that is going to put you in
this kind of range where I need to be
just go back up top so that if your way
back here right he puts this weapon up I
can't get his hands see so every on
right here okay so if you're doing this
stuff
okay let's go miss Venable so it's not a
trade-off it's not your turn my turn
okay so just aggressively he moves he
goes into contact I'm still going this
way
so if you will just obey the rules okay
so he's not there on the second move so
if I speed and come back to hear your
sense I went backwards
let's watch what happens stay there
so here's my speed range and he goes
this Bob it gives me his temple range
you see that and from here I go
backwards you see then he is that where
he kept his hands this is so I can touch
this in our line is back here you see I
miss so but this is what I need to do to
touch his hands so I'm off the power
line and if it was not embryonic he's
had to be at the top of his head and I
wouldn't be missing do you guys
understand so bringing hands a little
stop this is where I have to hit it so
the Jo has to be there and I have to
have that now my power line you see you
see that so that means my spine has to
be there so I can't move that I have to
move forward and around right so as I
know it I'm going this way
watch my right foot in relation to where
it was so
it's moving more that direction do you
guys understand yes so it's aggression
[Music]
the guy's tactic was to do a round start
it makes no sense to move into it its
power vector which is the apex there you
already went in it you're going to have
to cross it to get back out and you know
what does that when is for real
do you understand that slight car I'm
gonna run across the doorway when the
guys she got the doorway I'm not gonna
do that
let's see where I am okay so I was
inside the ions so I fight from the
inside the iris form do you get it don't
come back into her his power apex is all
right let's go so we do this same route
kami as we did
two weeks ago with the booking so he
can't hit my head before boots off my
bed in that okay so he goes over here
but did you see the majority of my
weapon is to the left even though I
counter to the right
so rather than pull this record over
here I'm gonna move myself behind my own
weapon so he does his ski and I moved
myself behind my other weapon always
attack me
[Music]
and I'm doing the same with you and you
tack this grip the grip is out when he
feels the ID the whole city the best
time to shoot
[Music]
okay so and I have to have tower
geometries okay get your hand out of the
way this this move has to be with my
body you can't be I'm over here don't
you see that disarm the job make him
have to be at the back end only it'll
clear the center line you got it so so
watch my bottom mechanics everything's
kind of move hit our body hits
okay you're just kind of casually
putting you saw your opening such as
hands out and break it okay let's go
okay so farm is going to do something
it's going to be pulse close as we
address on each other we getting closer
okay
and then it'll pulse open and rotate
okay so I'm doing the first move whoa
and I'm rotating and when I do this stay
where you are but there he goes okay so
here's my penetration range you see
where I am and he does his boot home and
then he does his ski and look how close
we are hi dizzy so usually what happens
is this guy does not penetrate on their
feet and then he has a lock last way to
go but this technique is he bronzed more
I read more into it and he's chasing me
down you can see that in fact he is not
in on me buddy come on again so if you
watch again so I pulled penetration I
was dumped this rifle bone I have
penetration we see status put it leg
back and because he needs that to get
out of the way of the ski so he can't
just go here but you see some people do
cuz there's no power so he has to
withdraw the jokes you see and then he
comes in boom and catches them so let's
try to smooth out the form so you can
see what happens to me as I run into but
this is where you can
then the next move makes no sense so we
do the same thing north north is a
withdrawal to see makes no sense so full
rein boom boom poop I'm getting the hell
out don't hesitate
miss be smooth full range and I'm gonna
take the price here is trying to
penetrate I'm gonna go round them let it
go
where he withdraws the joke that's where
I'm going to the conversation he traced
his spaceport right there
Andreea tactics front elbow lap in the
head this strike is the same strike as
the second strike
each time I've showed you what the true
rage would be okay when you go back and
forth because you're violating ranges
okay
so he had a seed just input got it and I
hit the back of his head so I cannot be
standing here how do you know that
because he's striking into the right of
the Joey's here so I put that on his
head and then I move back and here's
right he goes again I'm about here right
when he withdraws the job okay so I come
up boom this we have 45 that is where
I'm going to be if this foot is closer
watch what happens to the job so you
violating that angle so we're hearing
you withdraw whoa out I have to make
this fit right there okay let's go right
so the correct rage assumes more than
you are
okay so and also then the importance of
dominating the centerline for as long as
possible there has to be a reason other
than I like this thing
for why I'm not kicking punching
grabbing
okay so when we do the first smooth and
he does not control chase
boom and he does not he goes right from
your up do you see that so I know my
weapon is energy counter rise yeah Oh
[Applause]
what why do I keep floating around this
range because he's making otherwise I
would go to other weapons and the same
thing happens as we go on in the floor
oh yeah I'm keeping them out keeping
them out a lot of you guys are
withdrawing a joke here you're sliding
use your hands you see that
[Music]
but as my okay let's do it again
not here you got it
always always
[Music]
No okay let's go all right don't worry